[Music]
on this thursday night money on the mind
it's budget day in canada
measures that hit home the new help for
existing homeowners and first-time
buyers this is the beginning i think of
a longer-term strategy to rethink
housing the steps towards a national
dental care plan the billions for the
indigenous community and the military
fresh urgent pleas from ukraine to the
west either you help us now or your help
will come too late and the un's new
action against russia
ready to blast off into history is the
beginning of many beginnings the eve of
a landmark flight into the final
frontier
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the federal government has laid out its
latest fiscal plan for the country
finance minister christiaa freeland
delivered her second federal budget it
includes roughly 31 billion dollars in
new spending over five years with a
focus on what freeland calls fiscal
responsibility
our ability to spend is not infinite
the time for extraordinary coveted
support
is over
and we will review
and reduce
government spending
because that is the responsible thing to
do it is more modest in terms of
spending than what many analysts have
been expecting and it's predicated on
how quickly the canadian economy is
recovering we're going to break down
what's in it and what impact it could
have on you our chief political
correspondent david aiken is following
it in ottawa david there's a distinct
focus on housing absolutely donna ottawa
wants to double the number of homes
built in canada every year from 200 000
to 400 000 and it is set aside just
under two billion dollars this year to
do just that
there's basically a significant gap
between the housing we need and the
housing stock that we have
this is a down payment towards that in
the meantime canadians who have what the
government calls quote housing
affordability challenges may be eligible
for a new one-time only payment of 500
dollars when and how that will be done
tbd
those building a secondary suite in
their home sometimes known as a granny
suite will be able to get a new tax
credit of up to 7 500
there's also a raft of new measures to
help first time home buyers and the most
popular is sure to be a new tax-free
first home savings account
each person can put up to eight thousand
dollars a year into this account to a
lifetime maximum of forty thousand
dollars and any contribution to the home
savings account will be tax-free going
in and will be tax-free coming out mind
you this won't be in place until next
year
in place now though
doubling of the first time home buyers
tax credit to ten thousand dollars that
will apply to any purchase made since
january the first this is the most
ambitious housing plan
to tackle supply any canadian government
has ever put forward
and it's also just a first step
the government is also taking its first
step towards a national dental care plan
this is one of the initiatives pushed by
the ndp to start the government promises
to cover the dental care costs for all
kids under 12 who live in a household
with income of less than ninety thousand
dollars and that will start this year
helping ninety thousand kids the
government is also funding a two-year
pilot project to provide free menstrual
products
and while this budget keeps an eye on
job growth and fighting climate change
with smaller incremental programs there
is relatively significant spending on
indigenous programs an extra two and a
half billion dollars this year including
650 million dollars on housing and 460
million dollars on health care in
indigenous communities i think it's a
prudent budget it's a modest budget and
i think it's consistent with the
uncertainty that canada is facing
now the bottom line to all of the budget
measures is that they add up to net new
spending this year
of just seven and a half billion dollars
and that is on a budget of 450 billion
dollars so not a lot of new red ink now
the deficit right now is going to be
about two percent of gdp and it's going
to shrink all the way down to less than
a half a percent of gdp by 2027. donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thank you
there were high expectations for a boost
in defense spending especially given the
aggression from russia and nuclear power
and given the world is at this high
stakes moment more money is being
injected into the canadian forces over
the next five years but as abigail
beeman explains it's not enough to meet
what our allies expect
[Music]
the headline 8 billion dollars in new
defense funding over five years but the
details are extremely blurry 6.1 billion
dollars comes with a major focus on
north american defense and modernizing
norad a pledge to continue with nato
commitments in europe and a major
defense policy review to determine what
canada's military needs to be able to do
in a changing world
this budget will help provide
the fiscal
and physical firepower we need to meet
any threat for them to now allocate
eight billion dollars but over five
years
is
embarrassing
it is shameful
they're not even replacing the money
that they wouldn't allow to be spent
since they took office a senior
government source says the lack of
clarity is because more work needs to be
done with allies and canada doesn't want
all its cards on the table i think it's
predicated on the review and i think the
how this money is going to roll out
probably is going to be a result of that
of that work done at the front end is
probably the right way to do it the big
question of course will canada get close
to the 2 percent of gdp spending targets
set by nato it won't in five years
canada will hit 1.5 percent it sends a
very different and much less forceful
message to our allies
as well as adversaries about how
committed we are the new money means the
department of national defense's budget
will climb from about 25 billion dollars
in 2021-22
to more than 40 billion in five years
there are some specifics over the next
five years 245 million dollars to
support culture change including
modernizing the military justice system
nearly a billion dollars for ukraine
including half a billion in the first
year for military aid governments
planning to spend that kind of money on
equipping ukraine um you know that's
great but it'd be great to see that
level of urgency being put towards
equipping the canadian military
the government says canada has now
announced more than 1.2 billion in
direct aid to ukraine and up to 1.6
billion in loans and in the same chapter
the budget promises to clarify the
foreign affairs minister's ability to
seize forfeit and dispose of assets held
by those sanctioned think russian
oligarchs donna abigail thanks let's go
to our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson mercedes budgets we know are
political as well as fiscal documents
what do you think the government is
trying to accomplish
here well donna the government is
sending a message of fiscal restraint
which is different from what we've seen
over the past two years with covid but
now that kovit
has not wrapped up clearly but the need
for emergency
government supports is no longer there
we're seeing them revert to pre-coveted
spending levels while still trying to
maintain a lot of competing priorities
in what is a highly at times unstable
international system with what's
happening with russia attacking ukraine
there have also been supply side shocks
to the economy as a result of covid so
the government has to find a way to
spend on some big priority items that
have meaning for people's lives that's
things like inflation and housing and
well there's not a lot they can do about
the supply chain problems contributing
to that inflation they can offer people
something that they're looking forward
to in that housing promise of course
whether or not it comes through we'll
have to wait and see
mercedes as you say the finance minister
framing this is a fiscally responsible
budget how are the opposition
conservatives reacting
so the opposition disagree with that
analysis which is interesting because
there's some similar things in this
budget to their platform although it's
very different than what a conservative
budget would look like take a listen to
what candice bergin the interim leader
of the conservative party had to say
justin trudeau is basically taking money
that he's been collecting from canadians
who are suffering because of inflation
and he's using it to pay for the
promises that he made to the ndp and in
turn they're going to prop them up
donna the ndp will support this budget
there's still a lot of big spending
items to come things like pharmacare
that didn't make it into this budget in
part because the government is trying to
balance the situation where they could
see a change in the economy quickly so
those things are still coming down the
track potentially but for this year the
government taking an unexpectedly more
restrained fiscal approach than a lot of
analysts were expecting all right
mercedes thank you after a break i'll
talk to christian freeland about the
budget who she was thinking about when
she crafted it and whether canada is
doing enough to help ukraine stay with
us
with me now from ottawa is canada's
finance minister and deputy prime
minister christiaa freeland ms freeland
thanks for taking time for us
can i ask who you were thinking of most
when you crafted this budget the
canadians who were struggling
financially right now or our kids who
could end up saddled with a big debt
i i was thinking about
both groups of canadians actually i was
thinking and when i think about my kids
donna and your kids
and all the young people in canada
the thing i really think about is
being sure we have a canada
that has a growing economy
um
that to me is the single most important
job
all of us as a government all of us as
parents have because you know i think
about my own parents and my grandparents
and each past generation of canadians
has been able to
watch this wonderful thing happen which
is their kids be more prosperous than
they were that's the story of my family
i'm sure it's the story of yours
and i think we want that to be the story
of our children and to do that there's a
lot of work we have to do now
and that is definitely something that is
in this budget that's where the housing
part of the budget is very much focused
and yes that's where the fiscal
responsibility in the budget is focused
too
let me ask you about the banks you know
the six big banks made i think 46
billion dollars in profits that was in
2019
a lot of people were expecting they were
expecting i think a hike of uh from 15
percent to 18 percent on their earnings
above 1 billion dollars you didn't do
that today why not
we are raising significant revenues in
this budget
including from the banks
so financial services
are going to be paying
two
additional taxes
one is the coveted recovery dividend
it's a 15
tax
on financial services after the first
billion
for 2021 because that was a moment when
the federal government spent a lot of
money to backstop the canadian economy
and we think that it's fair
to ask those institutions that were
supported by that backstop to help us
pay off that debt and i can assure you
that 15 tax that's considerable on that
one year
and then what we've also introduced is a
1.5 percent
ongoing sur tax on everything above 100
million a gain for financial services
that's going to bring in significant
revenue and that's important
there are also a number of other
measures more technical in nature but
significant raising significant revenue
and those have been about doing
something which i think everyone kind of
suspects is happening in the tax system
but as finance minister i can tell you
is actually happening in the tax system
which is really aggressive tax planning
doing things which up until now have
been perfectly legal moving money to
lower tax jurisdictions
switching
profits from one form of income to
another things like that people haven't
been doing anything that's not allowed
but we've looked closely at different
actions that are legal but allow
significant tax avoidance
by people who have a lot of money and
those measures by closing those
loopholes really systematically we're
raising a lot of additional money too
and that's what has allowed us to put
forward a budget which is both fiscally
responsible
and invests a lot in the things
canadians need
okay i have time for one more question
defense spending it's increasing it not
to the levels nato and our allies
expected you heard ukraine's foreign
minister today probably he said his
agenda at the nato meeting in brussels
had three items on it weapons weapons
weapons he says he needs the weapons
before peop more people die
why can canada not do more
canada is doing a lot for ukraine in
this budget and i'm really proud of that
and i
totally agree with the ukrainians that
their first need is weapons
that's why there is
500 million dollars
specifically in this budget to buy
weapons for ukraine right now when
ukraine needs the weapons so and
look around at what other countries are
doing that is a very considerable
contribution by canada and i'm proud
that we're making it the other thing
ukraine really needs and we have all
been hearing this directly from the
ukrainians is they need some money
to get through the war because their
economy isn't operating right they are
under attack and yet they still need to
pay out pensions they still need to run
the society so they've said to us help
us to get some stabilization money and
this budget does that there's a billion
dollar loan directly to ukraine to help
them get through and we're working with
our partners to encourage other
countries to match canada's level and
then just the final thing since you've
mentioned the foreign minister in
ukraine that we do in this budget that i
really hope is going to bring the rest
of the world along
is we've extended our sanctions regime
so
right now we are able to freeze russian
assets
with this budget we're extending the
authorities to be able to seize them and
the idea is that those seized russian
assets can go into a fund to help
rebuild ukraine we're talking with our
partners to encourage them to do the
same thing because there have been
billions and billions and billions of
dollars worth of damage and i can't
think of a more appropriate thing than
for seized russian assets to rebuild
that brave country
finance minister christian freeland
thank you
pleading for immediate help coming up
what ukraine wants from the west before
it's too late
ukraine's foreign minister was in
brussels today delivering a blunt
message to nato leaders he says ukraine
needs more military aid right now
because thousands of people face
imminent death in the expected russian
assault on eastern ukraine just hours
before that rusher was suspended from
the united nations human rights council
crystal commansing reported a warning
her story contains disturbing images
the walls that once made up people's
homes
now rubble in the streets of northern
ukraine the cleanup seems futile yet
residents in cherny have worked to
create order in the chaos
across ukraine there are fears the worst
is far from over the battle for donbass
will remind you
the second world war with large
operations
the dawn bass in the eastern region of
ukraine is where there have been bursts
of fighting since 2014. russia
recognizes breakaway areas in that
region as independent states
nato now says russia is regrouping for a
major offensive in that area resulting
in pleas from ukraine's foreign minister
either you help us now
and i'm speaking about days not weeks
or your help will come too late the
scale of death and destruction in bucha
a city that was occupied by russian
forces for nearly three weeks is serving
as a reminder of what's at stake we know
that starting february 24th
with this further invasion by russia of
ukraine the world has become a more
dangerous place
and that is why we need to make sure
that our partners are well supported by
nato canada continues to supply ukraine
with lethal and non-lethal weapons as
well as financial aid a recorded vote
has been requested it also helped
develop a draft resolution to suspend
the russian federation from the united
nations human rights council
we reject the untruthful allegations
against us said the russian deputy u.n
ambassador ahead of the vote
24 nations voted in support of russia
including belarus iran and china
93 agreed that russian's actions equate
to gross and systematic violations of
human rights the rare decision this
assembly has taken today sends a strong
signal of accountability
the kremlin spokesperson dmitry peskov
says russia hopes to reach its goals in
ukraine in the coming days it's about
guaranteeing our future in his first
western interview with sky news peskov
admits russian forces have suffered
significant losses in ukraine calling
that a tragedy
crystal gamansen global news
london
the american supreme court will include
a black female justice for the first
time in its 233-year history the u.s
senate confirmed justice katangi brown
jackson to the bench today
on this vote the a's are 53
the nays are 47
and this nomination is confirmed
all democrats voted to confirm her as
well as three republicans she's 51 and
it's a lifetime appointment but it will
not shift the ideological balance of the
supreme court with its six to three
conservative majority
and historic mission readies for
blastoff next the civilians going into
space for more than just the view
not everyone in canada is struggling
financially there are people who are
extremely wealthy montreal businessman
mark pathy is one of them he has what it
takes to pay nearly 70 million dollars
to be part of a private voyage to the
international space station tomorrow
mike dralet on the latest travelers to
space
okay i've got your contacts a spacewalk
to fix the outside of the international
space station isn't in the cards but
this group won't exactly be space
tourists either a real estate investor a
former israeli fighter pilot and
canadian businessman mark pathy paid
almost 70 million dollars a piece for
the view and a job as admission
specialists over their eight-day stay
they'll be conducting 26 experiments the
commercialization of space now comes
with a twist
this is a very historic moment
and i think is the beginning of many
beginnings for
commercializing low earth orbit a
beginning or a symbolic handover of the
low earth orbit economy to the private
sector last year virgin galactic and
blue origin sent space tourists to the
edge of space but they only offer a
taste of it compared to the full meal
guests on the iss with axiom get it's a
pretty good thing that more commercial
and private companies are becoming
interested and are seeing the value in
space exploration and in the ways that
they can sort of
expand research here on earth 24 years
after the launch of the iss nasa is
focused on getting humans on the moon in
2025 as the first step towards a visit
to mars and when the iss is
decommissioned sometime around 2030
axiom is expected to have the first of
several commercial space stations
floating above the earth
likely filled with millionaires dabbling
in science
microlight global news toronto and that
is global national for this thursday i'm
donna friesen tonight's your canada is
little bow provincial park in the
village of champion alberta thanks for
watching take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you